vous rappeliez tous les deux ce baiser
là non c'est vrai c'est bien vous êtes
sincère pas du tout c'est loin des gros
bras s'est plusieurs fois j'ai embrassé
michèle morgan vraiment j'ai remarqué en
tout cas c'est que ce sont des baisers
très pudique à dans votre livre de
souvenirs avec ces yeux là pour vous
raconter que jean gabin vous a donné un
vrai baiser non à ce que vous le mettez
dans votre bain alors à 6 6 1
j'ai relu le livre tout à l'heure ah si
si si si il va les payer comment on
croit qu'on les fait matin non non
écouter dans votre est vrai baiser oui
mais dans votre livre vous racontez que
jean gabin avant le tournage vous dit je
te préviens jamais personne de
t'embrasser vraiment mais moi je te
préviens jouer dans votre livre
davant avait là c'est la manière dont
avec ces yeux là ça s'appelle si vous
avez écrit un seul livre d'ailleurs
oui donc je peux pas vous savez c'est
moi j'ai collaboré ollier vraiment je
n'ai pas écrit moi-même j'ai quand même
pas laisser écrire n'importe quoi comme
non mais ça ne voulait pas dire vrai
baiser comme on imagine un vrai baiser
maintenant à quel différentes éditions
s'étaient fait la bise et profond voilà
ce que je veux à l'époque moi je jouais
avec valentine tessier chérie je veux
faire baiser profond là moi je faisais
pas les mêmes non maintenant mais je dis
pas que c'est vous qui avez fait un
baiser profond - jean gamme c'est jean
gabin qui vise à fait indépendant c'est
ce que vous dites dans votre livre
écoutez là j'ai dit des bêtises
en tout cas vous vous rappelez tendra
pas céder et d'ailleurs
les eti mais ma il ya beaucoup de gens
autour il ya la caméra il ya d'éclairage
l'éclairage très important alors on fait
beaucoup plus attention à l'éclairage
jouer sa voix est ce que dans bones et
là c'est dans votre vie dans votre vie
privée est ce que des hommes amoureux
vous ont fait une déclaration en
commençant justement en se référant
incarné en disant t'as d'beaux yeux tu
sais ils le disent maintenant mais c'est
un pétard dans les quelques fois des
messieurs d'incertaines là je me dis ça
en madame
à l'époque j'étais tellement amoureux de
vous ben oui mais non mais c'est arrivé
qu'après non mais quelques années après
ce que cette phrase est tellement
célèbre michel oui c'est cette référence
elle préfère par exemple je lui rappelle
et ça aussi c'est dans votre livre parce
que encore une fois j'ai lu ce matin que
par exemple quand vous avez tourné
fabiola avec henri vidal et bien vous
gifle et 18 x 19 ça je m'en souvienne a
donc missionné des gifles et pas des
baisers pourquoi avez-vous